you okay no
um not okay
[Music]
it's having such a hard day today
The Fallout continues for yay his recent
anti-semitic comments have caused public
outrage it sucks you know when someone
doesn't see how different they are but
you keep looking for that person
I always will still always like hope
that you'll see a glimpse of them and
like
I hope I do Kim Kardashian broke down in
tears on the newest episode of the
Kardashians as she dealt with the
Fallout of Kanye West's anti-semitic
comments it's really confusing for me
it's so different than the person that I
married because that's who I loved and
that's who I remember and that's who I
you know
I'll do anything to get that person back
while sitting down with her sister Chloe
Kardashian Kim expressed how she felt
guilty for making a statement in support
of the Jewish community and how it might
have impacted Kanye's personal and
professional life I
you know then I like feel guilty that I
posted something in support of the
Jewish Community then people dropped him
today and I'm like is that my fault that
like no I posted that and did that like
push them and I should have just kept
quiet no it's not vocal about everything
else and it's like I never know what to
do the whole situation is sad and I
don't know how to emotionally manage it
like I'm conflicted because I don't ever
want to jump in and be a part of a
downfall for the father of my kids after
Chloe admitted that seeing everything
play out with Kanye was like watching a
car crash in slow motion she reassured
Kim that she can relate to the sense of
guilt her sister was feeling
Kim every single day I feel bad about
Lamar every single day yeah I feel bad
about Tristan not being on a team right
now Lamar is forever going to remembered
of being a drug user and his correct but
these are his these are Kanye's things
but that doesn't mean we don't feel bad
about it I'm not on your level and I'm
not going through what you're going
through right now but I can relate it's
okay that you're crying it's okay that
you have feelings you're such a good
person and that's why you feel like this
and that's why your heart is breaking
for him people have probably wanted to
cancel him for a while and he's always
said I'm not cancelable or whatever the
word is and now this is probably just
the last thing but this too shall pass